i think that we have actually moved from
being
having decisions taken based on data to
decisions taken
by date and my problem with that is that
i think that the data increasingly says
we could be unlocking before the 19th of
july
[Music]
former chancellor sajit javid was
appointed health secretary after matt
hancock
was caught breaking coveted rules in his
office so what's the mood of the tory
party like and will the new health
secretary be more keen to end
restrictions than his predecessor
i'm joined now by the conservative mp
and former international trade secretary
dr liam fox liam thank you for joining
spectator tv
so it's been a week of revelations
others might say rank hypocrisy
after hancock was discovered to be
breaking the rules he mandated the
nation follow how damaging has this been
to the tory party's reputation
and to the public's willingness to keep
following the rules
i think the public are willing to follow
the law i think that's one of the
key characteristics of the british
people i think that what is
irritating people at the moment is that
they see the rules
being applied in a very asymmetric way
too many
exemptions for reasons that are not
entirely clear
and a suspicion that we are now
following
dates not data you tweeted yesterday
that while brits are welcome in france
if they've had
two jabs they have to isolate when they
come back
meanwhile uefa officials come into the
uk and don't have to isolate
nor do apparently senior business
executives if they're thought to be
economically beneficial to the uk
strange languages i'm pretty sure small
businesses play a vital role
to the uk economy too it just doesn't
seem fair
does it it doesn't seem fair because it
isn't fair
um if you can go to france having had
two jabs because as public health
england have told us
these jobs will cover you against all
the known variants
and the french think that's perfectly
reasonable uh
that's one case uh you can't then come
back from france
uh with the same two jabs that cover you
for all the known variants to the uk
for reasons that i can't quite fathom
and i think it's that lack of
clarity and transparency that irritates
people
and i think people especially in places
like the travel industry
they are not stupid they can read the
data themselves
if we know the criteria on which these
decisions are being taken
then people can monitor the trends and
they can get an idea of where we're
going i think it's the
uh arbitrary nature of some of these
decisions um
the way that they change with without
much notice
and the fact that we're not clear uh
about the criteria because there's
a lack of transparency i think that is
potentially
a way to undermine public support and it
can so easily be managed uh
i was saying in the house of commons a
couple of days ago uh we need better
data right at the beginning you'll
remember
we were told so many people were
admitted to hospitals so many had
pre-existing
conditions and so on now we're just told
about the case numbers and the case
numbers themselves
don't actually tell us anything if
they're all children aged between 5 and
12
that's not going to overrun the nhs is
it
we should know which groups are actually
being admitted as is it people for
example who could have been immunized
but chose
not to be and in the hospitalization
numbers how long are people being
admitted for what's the net
number of people in hospital in flow and
outflow how many of them require further
treatment how many go on to icu
all these are bits of information that
would enable the public and parliament
to understand better the nature of the
decisions being taken
and all i'm asking for which i think is
not unreasonable
is the fair application of the rules and
greater transparency
about decision taking and what data
that is actually being based upon i
think that most people would think that
was an
entirely sensible and reasonable thing
to ask for i suppose those who would
defend
these exemptions would say look at
wembley this week where we saw
spectacular scenes of the england team
beating the german team
it was a wonderful moment for the nation
a huge boost to morale
uefa were threatening to take the
semifinals and finals out of the country
if they didn't get their exemptions for
thousands of vip guests
perhaps they defend it by saying well
this trade-off was worth it
well it may well be defensible
politically it may well be defensible in
terms of people's enjoyment
is it consistent with with the rules on
public health
apparently it is but on what criteria
i think that we have actually moved from
being
having decisions taken based on data to
decisions taken
by date and my problem with that is that
i think that the data increasingly says
we could be unlocking before the 19th of
july
and we should be looking at that data
we're getting increasing evidence
that the hospitalization and the death
rates are not rising in anything like
the same
proportions as the number of cases we
have there's clearly a break in the link
which is what you'd expect
when you've got a vaccine that covers
you against most of the variants
in fact all the known variants that we
have at the present time
and it seems to me that having begun the
vaccination program so early and having
given the british people a great
advantage that the government are
squandering that to an extent and that
what could have been a great vaccine
dividend for the british people
is being denied by an over-application
of the precautionary principle and at
some point
you know i'm i'm a medic before i i was
a politician
the medical profession will want to
drive the numbers down to the lowest
possible level
that's not the same aim as the
government the government needs to be to
make sure that the
there's not a higher level of infection
there needs to be
in at a level that's consistent with the
opening up of the economy
the maintenance of people's jobs the
running of the health service to a more
efficient level
dealing with some of the groups left
behind getting our children back to
school
and making sure that our families and
friends can be reunited because that's a
vital part
of our social and mental health so the
government's aims have to diverge
from their medical advisors aims at some
point i think we're at that point
it does seem increasingly likely that
the 19th of july will go ahead
after this four-week delay but how free
will we actually be
liam because it's clear that
international travel is certainly not
resuming
normal services anytime soon and if
people are worried about getting pinged
by test and trace and having to
self-isolate for nearly two weeks
their behavior may not return to normal
well there is a very big question
about tests and trace if we're not
actually in a public health emergency
and all our restrictions are lifted
after the 19th of july
what business is it of the state where
citizens go to eat
or drink um and there's a question then
about the validity
uh or and and the justification
politically and morally
uh of that system if we don't have a
public health emergency
that it's underpinning so i think
there'll be quite a big debate around
that
there's a new health secretary in town
now sachit chavitt with your
medic hat on as well as your politics
hat
on what do you make of this appointment
and do you think he's going to be giving
you the data that you were just talking
about that you're so desperate to see
well he did say in an answer to my
question in the house of commons that
yes
we would see more data so that would be
a great thing in fact i think it's a
good thing all around
um the the more that we can show why
decisions are taken
and people can understand the data and
empirical basis for decision making
the more there's likely to be acceptance
of those decisions so i
i hope that we we get that we are
entering a different phase
and it's a chance for sergio javid to
make his name i think as health
secretary by
taking the public and parliament more
into the trust of the government and i
think that would be a good thing all
round
for the public for parliament and for
the government you also said in the
comments this week that parliament needs
to be taken
in confidence i think you're hinting at
it here but to what extent do you think
that the government
has been ignoring its backbench mps
during this crisis
i don't think it's it's ignoring i think
it's just that we've had this odd
dynamic of
announcements being made by downing
street press conference rather than
proper discussion in the house of
commons we don't have proper debates in
the house of commons
because the system's being altered
because of covert
i think that one of the things that we
need to get if we're going to hold the
government properly to account
are changes in parliament itself having
ministerial statements where you get one
question but no follow-up
is no way to scrutinize an executive and
we need parliament to
go back to normal as quickly as we can
get it
so that the government can be held to
account and
and we can ensure that we get the
information that we want so we would all
win
from that parliament would be
functioning better the public would be
better represented
and the government would actually
function better as governments always do
when they're being properly held to
account even if they don't enjoy the
process
let let's assume that at some point the
rules that apply to the powerful
will apply to everyone else as we've
been discussing
are you worried about a system that
creates perks for
the double jabbed creating a new
two-tier system in its place
essentially the jab versus the jab knots
well
the aim then of course is for everyone
to take up the the jabbing i've had mine
um i would advise everybody um to get it
um it's no there's no compunction in
britain for people to get it
but people who don't get their
immunisation can't expect for example to
have the same international travel
as people who do get it that's always
been the case if for example
you decided you didn't want to get a
yellow fever jab you couldn't go to
certain places in africa
so the principle's no different from
before and i think that
people are perfectly entitled if they
choose
not to get the job they should think
about their own health and they should
think about
public health as part of their civic
responsibility
but if they choose not to get it that's
their right but they also have to
understand that with rights will come
responsibilities
and consequences we've seen
vaccine passports coming into the uk
without really so much of a discussion
in parliament at wembley for example you
either have to show
your job status or you have to show a
negative cova test this has not been
properly debated does that worry you
well
again i think that parliament needs to
be given more time um
and better uh conditions to to properly
have these debates
the way in which we've been doing
virtual parliament uh which has
basically restricted us to three minutes
is
what i sometimes refer to as the cbb's
parliament with a three-minute attention
span
um i think that needs to change um and i
think we need to be able to discuss
these things
more widely and in more depth than we
can with the time limits that we have at
the present
in parliament so that needs to change um
as for the international element i think
that's well established so i think
people who don't have a job
can't expect to have the same
international travel rights
and we have a right as a country to
expect people coming in to be able to
prove
that they've been immunized uh if they
want to be free to travel within the uk
the difficulty then comes as you alluded
to
about different differential rights in
the country between those who've had
jabs and those who haven't
that i think as you say has not been
really properly debated
and there are all sorts of conflicting
things there about the rights of
private companies of private facilities
to determine who comes in
uh to their facilities so it's a complex
debate
uh which as i say requires a lot more
than than we've been able to have in
parliament so far
last question liam i hate to bring it up
but there's already talk about upping
restrictions this winter to curb the
virus
what data would you need to see
including a surge in
infections or hospitalizations to decide
whether or not we need another lock down
dare i say
or at least more restrictions again well
if you saw
another covert variant different to what
to what we've had before that wasn't
just more transmissible
but was actually more deadly then you'd
have to think about it again
that's unlikely because the way that
viruses mutate
largely by genetic drift rather than
genetic shift
is is a generally is a slower process
and i think that you can expect that
these vaccines will
be effective for some time you may need
a booster jab
but but it will give a lot of protection
to the population
we will face um in all likelihood an
increase in the number of seasonal
infections that's not a reason to
uh put restrictions back on the
population we've gone through
flu pandemics when we didn't do that and
i don't think there'd be a justification
for doing it
and i think governments have to be very
very careful
that they don't use the justifications
of a public health emergency to restrict
our freedoms
and then apply that to conditions which
cannot really be described
as public health emergencies but are
more an inconvenience
i think we've got to be very clear about
some our differentiation in those in
those cases
liam thank you so much for joining me if
you enjoy what we do on spectator tv
then subscribe to our youtube channel
click the button at the bottom of this
video and then tap the bell icon
to make sure you never miss an episode
and if you want to subscribe to the
magazine
take up our 12 issues for 12 pound offer
you'll get three months of the spectator
in print
and online for just 12 pounds plus we'll
give you a 20 pound amazon voucher
completely free just go to spectator dot
co dot uk
forward slash tv offer to take it up
[Music]
you